every year the government spends far
more on equipping the military than it
does on say Transportation
infrastructure or stopping Fentanyl from
flowing into the country it's how big a
deal the ndaa is in the eyes of our
elected leaders anyway and to put those
numbers into perspective again over the
past decade the United States has spent
more money on the military than exists
on the planet in other words if you were
to collect all of the physical currency
that exists on Earth it wouldn't be
enough to fund the military for 10 years
in fact it wouldn't be enough to fund
the U.S government as a whole for even
two years we would get about a year and
a half out of all of the money on the
planet so if somebody asks you how much
does our government cost well the answer
is all of it it costs all the money